but right now we have the match-up that
many of you are waiting for in the
constellation bracket the final opening
round game it is xqc it is bruce lee and
we're gonna have liftoff pretty shortly
so let me ask you both last match the
opening round
are we just gonna expect the unexpected
at this point
i don't even know what the unexpected is
i think i think it's gonna be fun either
way i think uh there will be plenty of
mistakes and it's it's it's just gonna
be very enjoyable to watch
ludwig
oh sorry it wasn't my turn to talk so i
wasn't thinking robert what was the
question
[Laughter]
oh who's gonna win something like that
look i asked you if we're gonna expect
the unexpected or do you have any idea
what's about to happen uh on on god i i
think xqc shouldn't have gone live i
think it was a mistake he decided to do
it he's a streamer first he's the best
at streaming i have to admit that no one
puts in the hours that he does but i
don't know the problem with xqc is the
problem that most rumors have playing
chess chess is resident sleeper unless
it's fast it just is like like a 10
minute game if you're just playing
against a random doesn't have stakes
behind it chat doesn't care so you have
to do like three o's you know and then
xqc even more zoomer does like one o's
and if you're playing those you're not
improving you're just doing what you
already know because you don't have time
to think and develop new strategies so i
i think
the the amount of time he's put in is a
lot and i think he has improved but his
on-screen chest time has not been the
most efficient way to play chess
and do we know hikaru if xuc has also
received some off-stream coaching or
what's that not as far as i know i
certainly have not have not coached him
um
so maybe he's looked up some stuff
offline but i don't think he's taken any
lessons gotcha well i was working with
foosley last night and she was very
concerned about what if xqc is working
off stream and he's been stream sniping
and i think all players to some extent
are worried that people will know what
they're going to do
but uh she she kind of didn't know what
to expect either and i said i i don't
tell you just play your best stuff don't
wonder your pieces work through your
thought process i mean it's xuc do we
ever really know
i will say so he got banned right and
then he had like a 600 rating i remember
and then came back from being banned and
had like an 800 something rating so like
he grinded off stream and clearly you
know
put a little more effort into his games
it didn't have to worry about
entertaining chat because like he does
always think about what chat is being
entertained or not entertained by and
he'll move on very quickly so i think i
i wish he was offline right now i think
it would be
a much closer game if not a win uh the
fact that he's streaming i'm nervous for
him
well leslie who says she is white in the
first game she starts with her d4 she
loves her party hat in the london
so let's see how ex you see him responds
in the very first move
oh is he still doing puzzles
i yeah he's he's not he's doing puzzle
he's crushing the puzzles admittedly
let's listen in
i believe xqcl can i get a new
wow one game
good luck
maybe he's so confident that he wanted
to give foosley a 30-second lead
they had to wait they're gonna restart
the game
true
true
what do i even do here
gonna have to match this right
did he say what do i do on e4 i don't
like the queen's fun opening i think
it's trash
i'm the first move
i hate this opening i think i think it's
rubbish
what's he gonna do
i know what to do here he and i are
asking the same questions
just keep on doing with this
if i don't know what to do is black all
i do is mirror them for like the first
eight
and i think that usually works like you
can i don't even know can you just bring
your bishop to where his bishop is your
night to where that night is on the same
file it's fine
yeah
actually that's a very good decision to
bring this bishop out here because you
get to develop your queen side fully and
then you can push your pawn e6 without
blocking your bishop in at home so whoa
did frieza just make the move in point
four seconds i think she i think she
made a pre-move yeah oh my gosh
i i know she feels confident in her
london system
i
i don't know if moving in 0.4 seconds is
a great idea though right right get
where xqc is coming from because i do
hate playing against the london system
because i i'm so much more used to like
e4 or even like i don't know something
something
d4 is weird and i hate seeing it but
once you figure out that you can just
kind of mirror
you're good
okay
okay
now hikar you coached him so obviously
something you showed him what's going on
here what's going on here uh he's i
didn't i didn't show him this that's for
sure
[Laughter]
okay but he's gonna be down one pawn if
she takes which i assume she sees
already uh
but this is kind of a cheese in a way
because it's like maybe he feels he has
to do something right away to go for it
and if she doesn't take the plot e4
e4
oh no
see
i talked to foosley about this and oh
excuse he found it
he found it i talked to her about this
it's when you react
you trust your opponent too much because
xqc played e5
oh you know he did it for a reason but
she sometimes thinks that she'll blunder
without realizing that her opponent may
also make a mistake so we could tune in
to foosley to see her reaction now
because i don't think she's particularly
thrilled oh my god
i have to cut my losses don't panic
don't panic it's fine you know what
he'll take my bishop i don't need it
i didn't want it anyway
oh my god this is terrible
this is terrible okay okay
how did this happen
okay what if i just take him first well
i'll still lose a piece
oh my god he's kind of insane
if i go here
i don't know
he's insane
i'm gonna lose my bishop
oh my god i'm so bad oh my god what'd i
just do
oh my god
i'm sorry
i'm sorry i'm fannicking out today
you're a coach so can you explain this
blunder chain is that okay um
[Music]
this is worked on i can explain this so
when
he put e5 instead of stopping pausing
thinking about how many pieces she had
attacking the square because she the
perfect set up here she freaked out and
as she just said she's panicking so she
moved her bishop back as a way to not
commit to anything but she should have
captured on e5 because she has three
pieces attacking it only two defending
and now we see in the game she's losing
a piece but
well she lost a piece she still can
fight though because she can take she
took back this pawn i think that's the
best choice keeping more pieces on the
board she is down now a bishop for one
pawn but a lot of it let's ask you let
me ask you you see this position right
yeah white is cleared down material but
it doesn't look so clear does it because
there's still so many pieces on the
board yeah it's not that big of a deal i
don't know i i think it's fine like you
can come back from this because it's
like
you don't have a pawn on e file as black
which sucks white does uh and so you
know just you got to do your thing you
can still bring out your knight it ain't
that big of a deal like plus two minus
two i think you enough blunders will
happen that that's the variance you just
did yours a little early what do you
think agaro yeah i mean i think the main
the main problem with the position is
that since i did originally show foosley
the uh the london system is that none of
the principles none of the ideas really
apply anymore like all the basics that
that you look for they're just gone in
this position so that my main concern is
finding moves that that makes sense but
it applies to both players because
they're not open lines and so you kind
of have to maneuver your knights and
your bishops to the right squares and i
don't think this really suits either
player so i think definitely the game is
still very unclear
for sure and this is a pretty obscure
structure with pawns in f6 and g6 but i
think
f2c playing bishop f5 is a great first
choice and i wonder if he'll go castle
queenside because he has fewer pieces to
move out the way to get his king over
there right and the one thing i would
add as well that this is i think only
xqc that i've really seen this with but
it happens all the time it's his failure
to develop piece all the pieces on the
back ring usually leaves one side with
undeveloped he doesn't bring out like
the the rook and the knight on next to
the queen or he doesn't bring like the
rook and the knight next to the king so
this is the the main thing i've seen is
that he has this issue with bringing all
the force into the game but he plays
bishop d6 which is a great move
for sure and let's listen into xqc to
hear his thoughts
i'm fully trying to give you because i'm
plus two i know that i'm forcing better
development and i can i can get a long
range
uh castle here
i think he's been in this game because i
have more plugs on this side
maybe i don't know i don't know if i'm
doing it
little chat it's my economy see that
sugar flare what is that
what what is this animal think about it
it's a komodo
let me want to come on guys
why is that a komodo
that's great nah it forces the talent oh
my god oh my god
look at that
now his pawns are towered and the file
is open
the gates are open
the gates have officially opened it
sounds like he was gatekeeping there
was he speaking
bing bang
bang
this music is very soothing does have
any checks
dude another one
another one
more power
another one
i've never seen somebody so happy about
stacked pawns another tower
[Laughter]
that's disgusting
it makes the board look like
i feel like i'm watching lord of the
rings
yeah
they're just like hitting the ring with
the hammer
to get my my knight into play honestly
they're both playing very well this is
pre-moving what is this
i think the way x-cube plays actually
really difficult to play against
here's the thing
and we talked about it a bit
our coaching sessions are basically two
hour sessions one hour sessions where we
memorize a set of ten possible openings
and it all goes out the window the
moment xqc plays what is it two pawns
straight up on the on the right side
nothing i did matters anymore i don't
know why i'm playing the london system
but i don't know i don't know what the
hell this is what am i supposed to do
here
and so it's such a jarring jarring
difference and maybe it's bad
conventionally if you know what you're
doing but the thing is we don't
that's honestly that's a very fair point
and i've
talked i tried to talk that through with
bruce lee last night just like you're
not going to know what's going to happen
so react
to their moves right you shouldn't just
say i'm i have this strategy i know when
you do you should see what your
opponent's plan is and she missed the
first one right she missed that move e5
coming e4 but since then she's played
very reasonably so she's actually up
over a minute on the clock and that i
think will be very important in this
particular game because it's so close so
you know hikaru in this type of position
how do you think that
white should proceed and how do you
think xuc will be able to handle it if
the position doesn't open up because he
is an aggressive player yeah i mean i
think uh it's important that she puts a
rook on the c file tries to attack down
towards that that knight in the pawn
behind it but again it's it's a very
hard position i feel like both players
we're going to see mistakes i think
we've not seen the end of the mistakes
they're going to be mistakes from both
players going forward simply because
nothing is open they're no open files
really and with all these pawns it's
just very close so
figuring out this is where it would have
helped if xcc had done some puzzles or
had had some pattern recognition because
what he needs to do here is try to check
with the white king and it's not easy to
um come up with ideas to do that
yeah and right away well what what are
you thinking about in this position
because we know that black is up a night
for just one pawn but what would the
plans that you would devise what would
those be
i mean i think he knows right he knows
that that that file's wide open on h i
feel like there's something you can do
there
uh
i like it yeah
he's making room for his knight and he's
also i this this seems five head
hey car you sure you haven't been
giving xqc some pointers no i haven't
but actually i was always going to ask
his rating is 8 40.
he's been improving he's yeah he's
playing off stream because i thought his
ring was down like 650 or something so
yeah he was playing off stream then
quite a bit
i think you taught him a secret popega
system or whatever you guys call it
and it's just doing something that we've
never ever prepared for and it's genius
because when he tries doing something
like the scotch we saw what happened
when he does it his own way
it turns out to be a brilliant maneuver
yeah
but this is a great move by foosley
setting up a very dangerous tactic here
if he takes the pawn
oh wow
wow
he's not a wire is that you love that
because now the the knight's trapped
well you have to move the knight and
then you lose the pawn the knight guards
the pawn on d4
so you're removing the defender of that
pawn because if the knight doesn't move
then you take the knight with your pawn
and now you go knight takes pawn but i
will say the downside of this putting
this pawn here is is now much easier to
attack so once this queen say retreats
to d1 then this pawn is under attack and
the king is feeling a little breezier
but it is a great move and he's fine
he's
he's really on his game right now
and see actually ludwig this is where i
would tell you like when i say perfect
moves are not perfect if if i if a grand
master played this pawn push and took
the pawn i would say it's perfect but
based on where the ratings are i don't i
would say this is not perfect play
because there is very serious risk to
the black king here so when i do say
perfect usually it's because it's
considering how the quality of the move
but also the danger when you're gaining
material so it's like you're perfect in
your own way sweetie
exactly yeah
yes wow oh that makes me feel better
okay cool and frustrated had a very good
reaction let's listen on xqc's thoughts
to see well now that he's won a pawn if
he feels like his king is too open or if
he feels like he's everything under
control
yeah and time is important too
so here we have xqc
i like i like this better
this one this one's going to it's going
to die
because
that was already
[Music]
then he gets a free pawn
the move here would have been this over
my problem with it with a double that
slows down my pace and i'm running out
of time
do you guys agree with his big bang
certainization
more or less
this night have to be supported
this night
screen and she's
seeing the same things
with the pun
we cannot let victor fall
switch between both streams it's a
different atmosphere
shocking
don't fall
is showing great support to his pieces
though that is sweet whoa what is knight
of three oh
oh
big blunder incoming
he's thinking in his head right now was
this stupid or brilliant this doesn't do
much hello
he decided on stupid
the fortress
look
they're all supporting each other
as one
professor xqc said that as one got taken
down
but i think it works professor xqc you
know
bang bang
i mean i think it's good because like
people don't think about night pins a
lot and they come up one wrong move with
the queen and you just get a free
picture
check
take
take not gonna do that check
check moves it takes
something i want to explore i don't know
i'm not trying to think about it man not
much i'm thinking about it bro
i would say the one downside of the
queen trade is
sorry what were you saying roberto
seems wishful
this is it
i'm evolving this don't blunder don't
ponder don't wonder
is there a check we can do here
as the hero would say no tricks
available
thank the queen
i think three minutes is more than
enough i feel like it's very late right
it is time for battle
it's a lot of time but
if you trade off too many pieces and the
pawns come off then it will be hard to
win so that's the only thing that i'm
looking at so he he's often the trader
brooks is great because the rook on d1
was trying to come to d7
but
if you trade too much
and your pawns get off the board then
it's going to be very difficult
correct although i think the fact that
xuc has brought the last rook into the
game the one piece that he was on its
original square um
i think he should win this game now um
the only reason that i think maybe he
won't win this game is if he blunders
one of his knights if he blunders a
knight that's really the only danger
that i see here but as long as he makes
relatively quick moves i i it's hard for
me to see a way for there to be tricks
that will that kind of like are real
blunders that's that's sort of the way
that i
i just don't see it here with only one
rook on the board and this makes it
easier for them too right like foosley
usually trading the rooks
so yeah i mean that was the one thing
ledway is also like when you're ahead
like you don't even mind if you make
some of these exchanges because it just
means your opponent doesn't have any
pieces so like you really can't tunnel
vision when your opponent only has like
one rook or a bishop and a knight
because it's only one thing that you
have to worry about like attacking all
your forces yeah my dream is baiting out
a trade for every single piece and then
i can just go through with like my
remaining piece and then like kill all
the younglings you know all the i'll get
all the pawns out of there make my queen
this is what we were talking about with
nim too i think
i think there's no chance he loses this
i i'm saying that and i'm nervous saying
it but
really i feel like with this much uh of
an advantage
he can just trade down everything and
then he'll he'll be able to figure it
out with the time remaining
yeah i think i think he should be able
to i think a lot depends on how quickly
he moves here this is the main danger is
getting too low on
on time
good move knight to d2
now will she see rook d1 is another
interesting question too
because then that knight can't move
right you were just telling that ludwig
seeing these night pins
not easy but here rook d1 puts that
knight
under threat the rook is defending it
but it can't move and that can be
frustrating
and
[Music]
she needs to figure out as well she can
play f3 here which defends her opponents
under attack and we actually have her
stream up we can listen in so let us go
to fousey right now i don't know if i
should move my rook here oh i should
move my rook here probably to pressure
his
is that how it works
keep the pressure on him right right
yeah why am i running
i'm attack you
frick actually this is not very helpful
oh he's like
looks like she's making both moves you
talked about
i'm in a bad situation
x2cc responded really well to protect
the knight
with the knight
time's running down
i wanted to do
keep sneaking my pawn by maybe maybe
he'll make it maybe he won't even notice
what
oh that's fine
i knew that was coming
okay so say i go here right this is
where i'll begin thinking five moves
ahead i go here right he has to move his
this right so he'll like go somewhere
else
um or wherever right yeah she pointed
the two that would be very convenient
what
maybe i could force him into a stalemate
i think it's very important she moves
fast she's down one minute on the clock
[Laughter]
yeah
yeah
she said she could request a draw that
is that is a clever tactic i think xqc
would be the last person on earth to
ever accept a draw in any position i
think he'd also be the first to
accidentally click it though
also probably true yeah uh yeah i i feel
like i've been in this spot she's in
that spot where you're like you're
you're down so much you're nervous you
don't know what to do
and all you do is like you make efforts
so for example when i see a pawn walking
towards being a queen and i'm like two
spots away with my king i follow it even
though i can't get there in time i know
that and i know when it becomes a queen
i can't even enter the zone but i feel
hopeless and powerless like i must do
something
mm-hmm yeah that makes a lot of sense
actually and actually she can start by
taking one pawn with check and then
taking the second pawn over here and
icarus what we were talking about
earlier where there were many queen side
pawns but if you lose two of them over
there that's where it starts becoming
difficult
right i still think he should win this
because i don't see how white's gonna be
able to take all the pawns without
losing some of your own pawns on on b2
and e2 but again it's not it's not it's
not over yet and the main issue is again
that she's so far behind on the clock
that um
that i think it's going to be very hard
for her to find these moves because i
think she's panicking a little bit
already she did express that last night
she was like oh xqc always just bullet
like he he does that bullet
and i don't i don't i don't no i can't
do that it's too quick so in time
trouble it's going to be difficult for
her she does have the five second added
to her clock with every move but she's
not used to it right exactly yeah
i am getting nervous because i
definitely don't think he's gonna be
able to find a mate with just a rook in
two
nights
uh at least in the time frame so
yeah i'm getting a little i feel like
this is still fine though he's still
fine he's fine right
he should be fine but it's yeah it's
getting a little bit tricky
yeah and you know just reminder to
everybody that no matter what happens in
this game there will be a second game so
let's say xqc does convert this fousey
will have a chance to come back and so
it's a two-game match get each color and
king e6 was a good move but i'm really
worried that he might go king d5 next
move and blunder rook d7 this is what
i'm really worried about oh good call
that's why i don't like this move at all
because you're going with some of the
principles oh wait i would have done
that too
yeah
yeah don't say that
no it's a great move what a great move
that would have been
well let us go to xqc right now and hear
what he's thinking in this position come
on you got this
love that
that's a great
it's not the same though
she found it
look what she did oh oh there's this
check oh i only thought it was d3 okay
oh no
it's okay i can just drag it to my knife
[Music]
it's crazy the whatever real chess
terminology he knows it's flagging
go go go go go go go go go go go
there's no right play here
come on
[Music]
um
love a blog
wow that was a sick idea
check my discovery
check my discovery
okay can we talk about queen
knight
queen knight check mates
what has
is how do you do that
it's the same way you do with a king and
a queen actually you just leave the
knight far away and then you just use
the king and the queen oh so the night
doesn't even matter right oh yeah that
makes sense that makes sense i think
that's the simplest way to think about
it it's just you know how to mate with a
queen and a king yeah you can even give
away your knight and then do what you
would do without it
do we know if he knows how to do that
uh i think he might and
he would i've definitely never shown him
how to mate with a king and a queen
but you showed him discovery tactics
with the queen on eight checking no i
didn't show him any of that i think this
is just odd this is just off stream that
he that discovered tactic was great
yeah he's really improving
he just made it a lot harder on himself
to have to win like this rather than
with rook and queen
right oh i'm nervous for him now
he's plenty of time though
yeah
she offered a draw
hey yo that's funny
he's scoffing damn i've never seen him
make that face okay king and queen let's
see if he knows it okay he did it
so for this one
what do you go what do you guys call it
you force it into one of the corners yes
and once the king gets in the corner you
stay away from these two squares because
if your queen is on these squares and
the king's the corn it's stalemate so
you have to be very careful okay show
this to fussy last night actually
okay
so the simplest way to do this
and he's doing a great job
is you want to keep your queen a nice
distance away from the enemy king except
when it's all the way in the corner as i
said if you have your queen a nice
square away then it's stalemate because
your queen will take away the remaining
squares
i like that it's a very stressful way to
go king of five don't go king of five
it's stalemate
oh no no
no
no no
oh what a game he played too
oh
xqc no
oh my gosh oh and the song end is just
radio silence
i win though right i went to my
window right
because she was white
and she was a hard one
well i i mean the the issue i have with
that is that he gave up the night
and the only reason you should give up
the night is if you're a hundred percent
sure you know how to make the checkmate
um
and he didn't know he didn't know how to
make the checkmate with the king and the
queen so
that's that's my criticism is that he
should not have given up the night
unless he was a hundred percent sure
that he could make the checkmate
yeah that's important
yeah
i will say i don't it's not a natural
thing i don't think to like figure out
how the checkmate works because you
don't really think in terms of
uh stalemates and what your opponent
can't do
right so i i only
kind of learned recently i do it like
like it's a rook king that's the only
way i know how to do it otherwise i'll
stalemate that makes sense too and the
technique from like the starting point
what i was saying was that keeping the
knight the queen and knight's distance
away is that if the king goes to the
side
you follow it one square over if the
king goes back diagonally you follow it
one towards the queenside diagonally if
the king comes diagonally to the right
you follow suit but the one time you
stop is right here because if king to h8
if you bring your queen here this king
has no more squares than stalemate
so you stop right here and then you dart
your king back to help to deliver the
checkmate because white can only move
these pieces here and for all 85 000
plus you welcome i mean this is
xqc versus floofy now game two and
you just learn how to check me with a
queen of the king vs kane
yeah
yeah a bit of a shame um that he didn't
close it out but i mean he did play
really well the whole game i mean he had
enough of an advantage that he was like
plus five or six at peak so
yeah uh if he gives himself just an you
just gotta give yourself an easier mate
that's it
mm-hmm maybe yeah pony but you know at
least i can do queen rook mate
yeah i think queen and rook most people
can do but just the queen is certainly
harder um for sure but but i think yeah
the main thing that i would say is that
he should not have given up the night
unless he was 100 sure that he knew how
to make the checkmate
um
that was the main main issue
yeah it's and now it's unfortunately
you're in this position where you're
probably kind of criticizing yourself
you're not going to be as objective
about the game because you're still
beating yourself up over the first game
and right what the great thing that
fussy has done she has played her
openings very quickly and she didn't end
up in time trouble in the first game but
she's already up almost a minute on the
clock and we have the keracon set up
here and good move by xqc to protect
this pawn
did you show her this or not i did
look at her go
so what i told her and for everybody
watching is that this bishop one move
ago if you put your pawn to e6 where you
want to go the bishop gets stuck so you
develop the bishop out and that way you
can play e6 with a very strong pawn
structure and everything is safe and
sound effort everybody who's new to the
channel here this is game two whoever
wins this game moves on to the
quarterfinals and assuming the
semifinals and not only do they do that
they play ludwig our lovely commentator
alongside us here so if this is a draw
it goes to the 3-0 it goes to a blitz
game okay
i understand best of two now
you just get white and black and then we
get to the blitz and
well that should favor xqc because he
just showed in that last game he is kind
of a speed demon and for foosley
sometimes when she's not sure of herself
she spends quite a bit of time and here
she's doing well though put a bishop
back on g6 it was under attack and now
her bishop's putting pressure in the
center
yeah i think d openings are i don't i
don't see him a lot and i don't like
them so i am mad that you taught this to
foosley
uh and he carved you just have a moment
just later on today if you can just
teach me like what i might do here
that'd be great that'd be great wow okay
well also
you know
i don't know what to say let's listen to
foosie
i don't know what my next move is um
it's probably something like push this
hat move uh
yeah push this up
see so right now
okay he also i realized he just had to
do this
his like if he castles this way his king
side is super weak so that's like pretty
good for us
um
sure
i'm gonna do this finish off my hat and
then i'm gonna do this
i might like to push this pawn as well
maybe if the if
so is he gonna castle this way
so far it looks pretty solid for her
yeah i feel like she's doing what you're
telling her to do but she does not seem
confident doing it
well my
rule number one to her was be confident
and it did easier than done yeah it's uh
and then the second rule was just win
forehead so you know it seems like she's
doing some of those uh yeah i think she
did bring up good points that it'd be
tough to castle kingside i if i could
predict xqc probably loves castling
queenside because it has an immediate
threat with the rook i like castling
queen side too because of that so i
assume that's probably prefer to do if
you can even get that bishop out of
there yeah i was gonna say i noticed
this game against hutch he did push the
pawn and develop the bishop like he did
play b3 bishop b2 move so if he actually
comes up with that it'll be very hard i
think for uh for foosley to react to
that because she's used to getting the
bishop on this d6 square on the star
store with the pawn formation around it
and then attacking towards the king but
here she's not going to actually get
that because i assume xc is going to
castle the other way
well the best thing for fussy about the
capture if we just go back and move is
she doesn't play knight f6 which allows
that e5 push which we saw in the first
game so with the capture
that tactics out the window but there's
a queen on e2 there's a k98 so will xqc
see this pawn hanging on d5
right oh that's a tough that's a tough
find
i don't think that's too dissimilar of a
skill from like finding a discovered
check though
now the one i think is
it depends how they castle the kings if
xqc does not castle the king king
this xqc is a different animal
what is happening this guy's a beast
that hey same animal different beasts
whatever the phrase is he's he's on to
something here hey you're you're the lit
major here don't you don't
don't question yourself
uh yeah that's i honestly i love
everything he's doing because at the
level we're at
things like this get you so much mileage
for sure
pins and discovered checks are like just
they're so they're so good because
nobody sees them and they'll fall right
into them
right very true yeah
yeah i mean i think really the question
is what happens here is who
castles which way
i mean i if they both cast their kings
to the same side which should be the
queen side i think the game will still
still go on for a long time but if they
end up with the kings on castling on the
opposite side somebody's going to be
getting checkmated right and the white
king as first you were saying earlier
it's going to be hard to castle
especially now with this rook on h8
staring down here your rook is needed to
protect that pawn but let's listen to
the xqc and hear his thoughts about this
position
he wants he wants to say and just take
it
there it is
if i did this
and it uh it would have been better
no it wouldn't have been better actually
yeah i think what he did was great but i
i feel that sentiment that
it seems lazy sometimes
and one of the earliest lessons you guys
teach us is that you know
just trading doesn't seem like the best
option all the time right
let me think about this
not bad
what did he do to protect the queen here
i have to be
hey
queen trade take it
this is so risky this is so risky is
this a risky risky you guys think
it definitely
want that so is
your first time you get nothing in life
dude
he's so nervous to do it
he's spending so much time just fighting
his better judgment and then you're not
even listening to it
give me give me me
yeah it is risky for sure
because he his king's in the center this
movie is clean about my god
next movie is even sicker
[Music]
check
no but she's gonna move the queen like
over here something like that she knows
[Music]
everywhere
okay that's a free night
wait
what
yeah
yeah i think this is a tough spot
because like your queen is so scary
being there
oh
what about this case
okay
no it wouldn't be that easy there's no
way
come on this is not real
this is
i mean this would be checkmates
no way
my queen we're gonna give my queen
not this not this not this
i have to
i have to get it
i think we would all perform 500 points
above our level if we just had somebody
there saying yeah man go for it
i'm happy to be your husband
rob i'm going to employ you all right
i'll pay you 725 it's federal minimum
wage
you just got to say hey man yeah go for
it that's great
okay that works for me that seems like a
fair trade
uh now x you see it's in a similar
position in the last game right he's
just kind of crushing
yeah pretty much
the only issue is again he has to the
one thing that i said earlier still
applies he has to remember to get all
the pieces into the game because the
bishop and the rook are still on the
queen side the bishop and the rook are
still on their original squares that's
the only issue he has here
that's right and his king is a bit
unsafe his king will be safe from
castle's queen side but if he feels like
he needs to get his king out of the
center because like that's what all the
coaches taught me and he goes to the
king side that's when this rook and even
if not for the rook captures the pawn
here there's a lot of open space in
front of the king
whoa oh no
that's a free pawn right yeah
yeah that's a lot of material happening
here also knight here is very good as
well hitting this queen
threatening his bishop
i think what we'll see is xgc trying to
force a queen trade eventually
maybe yeah i think as long as as long as
he moves the knight takes the pawn or
moves it to the c6 square he's gonna
reach an end game where foosley only has
one rook or two rooks on the board
and that's very critical that he reached
that because he's using way too much
time here so i think knight c6 is the
move that he should play
and i've seen him hovering over that
square he's been kind of looking at it
but there's one
big downside to that move and because
you think of capturing pieces so if
knight c6 queen to d7 and oh i blundered
my rook here and then you say oh i
blundered my other rook here this is a
moment and i know it's pretty far down
the line where even though white is up
many rooks two of them this king on e1
is really unsafe because this queen's
coming in with some checks right exactly
yeah i mean knight c6 is the is the move
that i think he should play but we'll
see we'll see what he's going to do he's
he's using way too much time here though
that's the one thing i would say
um that's why i feel like at this point
it's super critical that he plays one of
those knight moves right away
so he's got it he's got to just trust
himself and play knight to c6
he's also been looking at this queen
check which is actually very good
if he can find that because then the
knight will capture so if there's a
check on this king the king can't go to
these squares so the king would have to
go to f8 and once the knight captures us
check to the king and to the rook right
i think he's gonna go for it
i'm still worried about his clock though
yeah the clock situation is the big
issue here for sure i think the upside
is that he does go for it i think the
upside is that even if
uh
he does
end up drawing this he has so much
upside in the 3-0 as well like even if
he like he has to like uh i figured we'd
keep calling it right well
yeah but the problem is also i don't
think it's going to be easy to draw
because there's still going to be queens
and rooks on the board that's that's why
i think it's still very unclear here in
terms of what's going to happen
because if he had moved the knight to
one of the other squares he would have
been able to get a queen and a bishop
off the board whereas here he's going to
be giving up a knight for one rook so
black still will have a queen and a rook
on the board which is more than enough
firepower to create threats and maybe
even checkmate ideas
right
and fussy she was thinking about
blocking with her queen but then she
recognized that for white the knight and
the queens
uh take care of that square so
queensland would be a bad move
and
i've seen her hover i hope she
recognizes that her king can also move
this does seem tough though what is like
is there a correct response or is this
is this uh there's only one movement
it's king to f8 only move that's
playable here
typical uh scenario of zugzwang wouldn't
you say
oh she played it oh oh
oh wow okay okay so we'll i think excuse
me should be able to win the game now
because he has an extra queen and he's
got a lot he's got bishops and rooks on
the board um
so i think he should be able to win but
again we've seen stranger things happen
we certainly have and i really think she
just forgot her kink and moved because
she's so often taught don't move your
king right get castle so if you move
your king you're no longer castle so you
mix and match different ideas and
unfortunately blunders happen in this
particular moment so let's listen to her
stream to see if she still feels like
she has a chance or unfortunately she
feels like she's defeated here
where are my pieces they're all gone
okay i've decided excuses he is just
better than me that during at least
right now i mean like at this moment in
time
this happened two games in a row i just
slowly bleed bleed pieces
including my queen so sad this is i'm
getting sad guys yeah this is this is
this is yeah but i mean he's still using
too much time so i don't think it's like
i know he's winning but he's using way
too much time
that's true two and a half minutes
counting down guys he's using way too
much time here this is maybe if i attack
his queen here
right
that's not a bad move
i guess one of the big downsides for her
as she's like saying her next movie
pawnee six to attack the queen is that
it's all telegraphed like why would you
put the pawn there oh it's attacking the
queen so he'll retreat his queen
but he castles which is not a good move
castles okay
fine
now he's just got him he's just got to
move but again he's tunneling this is
sort of what i'm saying before where
he's not bringing the rook and the
bishop into the game
right
and
you know as we see here he only has
under two minutes a minute 50 seconds
counting down
and there are some chances for her if
she sees in the future that his pawn h3
can be captured and she can swing her
other rook into the game i mean he's
just got him moved like this is crazy
what is he doing what is he doing
he finally dropped his queen back there
good move too protecting the spawn i
don't know if he sees the h3 take
but i mean i'm thinking that maybe he's
just forgetting about the time actually
i think he might just be forgetting that
he doesn't have have that much time left
that didn't have enough not thinking
about it papa plata i mean the same
thing he was shocked when he lost from
timeout true true yeah
well let's listen to xqc and hear what
he's thinking in this position where he
is up a queen
so i can i can recover
the game
every move will be expensive at the
beginning but once the mat the mental
map is all mapped out
it's all about playing not about
thinking
and he's gonna stop
stop moving and please you're annoying
was a very good play
the time
guys he's thinking too long
yeah i did not foresee this
like this also works
okay i just hope he says something about
the time so i know that he knows about
it
takes takes
takes takes takes takes takes takes
five seconds of your move i need to
think about how he was like
okay one of my goals
get this up that up and get my dude out
of the way get my dude into the file for
position
and not lose pieces and move fast these
are my goals these are my goals
this is my planning and these are my
goals that i need to do
that's what i'm gonna do he seems aware
of the time though at least yeah
don't lose pieces
engage all the pieces then we can start
thinking about to do that's a good move
by frusty though one
should confuse him by bringing her rook
in
what's happening
he's getting a little stressed
he is i don't know what's happening
the lines of this song is
throwing me on a wild ride
come on
these moves are so odd
that's a good move
so now rookie one is the critical move
will xcc rook to e1 because he was
highlighting it before will he see it as
a big question
oh he does see it he just needs robert
has to be there going like yeah man you
got it yeah well he's gonna pay me 750
right i'm doing fine 725 come on robert
excuse me
i that way i would leave you as your
height man to go to him ah i see i see
i'm doing fine
so she should take the pawn h3 i'm doing
fine
the problem is i think queen takes pawn
is too obvious yeah this is huge that is
that is
huge but i don't know if she'll see rook
d6 it's a very difficult move for
treating the rook to protect the pawn
move
ping
if she doesn't do anything crazy here my
next move is going to be insane
okay there you go
i don't like this at all
so his force check made in two moves
will he see this
this is this is fat
i think he's gonna
move i'd still get this i get this i get
this 100 percent
is there that's right here for uh
he takes though okay for black
not really no but knight d7 check forced
the king to the center and it was
checkmate it still should be winning
but it's easy to get scared of two rooks
barreling down the h file towards your
king the one good thing is i don't see
if i don't see a checkmate pattern right
so as long as he moves quickly here
he is down to under gotta move though
yeah under 50 seconds
[Music]
oh
he's in serious time trouble now this is
a good check
47 o'clock come on
i don't have enough time to think when i
i can't think i have to just go fast
he recognizes king was in danger so he
moved to towards the center where he's
more pieces okay and then and then now
we we need to gather time
and i'm i'm only playing together 10
minutes i'm only playing to get a timer
i'm only going to play to just get to
get some time get my color back up i
need to supply and i can do this this
what are the easy ones i can do i can do
i can do this this is good it takes
takes i can do this i do take take what
is this what what else i can do i need
to take take
not take take it's even better
move that's good
take
over here
this
take take take
take okay
you know even as more take okay
i think he can just you know
go go super speed or whatever it is
yeah he can just move then there's no
danger because there are only rooks on
the board here so
unless he allows a stylemate he should
he should let's just get the pawns out
of there man just do the pawn race
there's no point even trying any
anything else
why bother dude just get some time
do the pawn race
bing bang bang bang promote takes takes
that's it i don't have to worry about
anything else i have to worry about is
this not killing anything this this this
structure is very good for everything
all i have to worry about is nothing i
don't worry about anything
yeah let's go let's get out showing
seriously good records throughout
today's match
the crazy thing is he sees all the
important stuff and then he even sees
the stuff that you wouldn't think about
like a rook taking a pawn
and then dying like he's looking at that
i don't know why he's looking at him
running out of time though she's gotta
move two seconds on the clock
yeah baby there it is big win big point
jump up too
wow he is amped and
i just
but we will be right back in a bit
because well when he calms down we'll
have him on for an interview to hear his
thoughts on what was an absolutely epic
performance
and we are back bringing on both foosley
and xqc xqc man what an effort by you
you played phenomenally well
oh thanks adam
i mean like what are you been doing how
you been practicing
um
okay
so i feel bad about this okay but i i'm
just gonna say [ __ ] up
um
i've been like busy with a lot of stuff
so
i haven't taken hickory's lessons but i
watched a couple of his videos and his
streams when i have time
and
a couple of tricks
like the smallest small things like two
or three things that i picked up on like
made a crazy difference like even a
small like there's two things key that i
mean they made the cruise difference
it's moving the the rooks on the pile at
the bottom and and
at the bottom unfolding the pawn
so i can i can move my
um
the bishop
across the to the rook and these two
things like made a million more options
for the game
yeah and firstly well it was a tough
match for you you did survive that first
game because of stalemate so did you
feel like you had some chances or did
you feel like well i mean honestly xuc
was out playing you he was out playing
me i could feel it he does he's super
aggro and so i kept he would take a
piece and i'd take it and
like mess up my pawn position so i was
like damn and he'd do it again and then
again and then i'd have all these
stacked pawns and then i was just all i
could think of was lessons that people
were saying like oh you never want your
double pawn double pawns are bad double
so i'm like
and then like that that i just started
to crumble um so i was hoping for a
stalemate uh in the first round and we
got it
uh and then the second round yeah i just
i forgot the timer i i didn't even see
it
i was like wait how did i maybe did i
win
xqc i got to ask you about your opening
because it feels like every player has
had a coach and knows their first eight
moves by heart and what you did confused
every person watching what did you plan
your opening or are you just winging it
well what i notice is that i have one
two openings on white but i have no
opinions for black
and when i'm black i use my i use my
board
backwards right to where they get you
know the website puts my black at my
position
and everything is inverse i feel like
i'm in a i'm in australia i'm like
upside down dude and that didn't make
sense you know what i mean so i was just
winging it but it's why the opening was
so trash
yes you kept playing d and you you just
said you had nothing for that you just
had nothing for like a defile opening
yo
i didn't know what to do she kept
opening like like sideways
and and queen spawn what is queen spun
what is that opening what do you do with
queen's pawn i don't do it against that
but it's almost good in a way because
the thing is like all of us are coached
to do the first 10 moves and we're
supposed to respond to good moves but
you don't do good moves you do your own
thing that we have no idea how to
respond to because it's it's no one
teaches you oh yeah he's gonna bring up
the b-pawn then the c-pawn that makes no
sense yeah it clearly ended up working
out
yeah i i i noticed right there at the
beginning
like i put all my pawns like like
planked up at the top and i was like
dude what am i even going with this man
like i don't know what i'm doing with
this and i was like if somebody
like if you plan this opener out right
it makes sense but that's what i thought
i thought this makes no sense but it
doesn't make sense to her either
you know it makes no sense no
and bruce lee actually at this point
here when x6 played e5 he had this great
idea of trying to win your pieces but if
you counted how many times he's
protecting the square 95 compared to how
many times you're attacking so you could
have taken this pawn here and when he
takes you back you could take again with
the knight because your bishop is here
protecting it i know i tunneled i i
couldn't
question yes is that is that what you do
when you pledge it
i always refer from doing that because
that was stupid but you actually have to
count how many times is protected like
like pawn thing that's one rotates
that's two bit of that's three you count
them
yeah
you should always you should always be
alert to see how many pieces are
protecting the square
okay it makes sense
it was well played games i every time i
thought i had him i would like okay next
move there's no way and then he'd find a
move that like counted both that like
both possibilities and like
so
i deserve to lose
i mean
i have a question for you xqc
yep that we had ludwig on doing
commentary and then i realized that he
was playing the winner of this match so
you play him next so right now you're
all friendly but what do you want to say
to ludwig are you facing the semifinals
yeah i don't want to make too much spice
okay
but listen ludwig is kind of a friend
from high school who played like 2000
games of league and he's still silver
that's that's kind of how it is so i
guess i'll see you next round dude but
if i put a bit more time dude listen
you're not making it through put the
diamond but i would i would put i want
to do a little sideways here i'll give
100 subs if you beat me you don't want
to put anything up
oh yeah i'll match it 100 seconds
yeah oh easy money sherman
it finally launched one an ad i'm
kidding i i listen
look i know your plays i've seen you
discovered checks you have great pins
i'm watching out for him though and hey
guess what my opening is
d4
i only play d4 now
can you teach me d4 by
[Laughter]
i'll make sure to not sleep before i'm
gonna do the craziest response that you
you will not foresee and every scripted
move will be absolutely obliterated and
crush underfoot
that's so scary but i'm gonna be ready
for it
and and win
listen
there's only one one that comes out of
the next match buddy and he's gonna be
me
bam
i'd love to see it you're you're high
and mighty look i'm happy you won a game
but let's look at the record xqc
listen i got momentum one of my good
friends always say speed violence
momentum and then that's in my favor
so you have to wind it up a little bit i
can't beat that if he's got that on his
side that's pretty that's pretty hard
wait look you went from super confident
to now being he's got
he's got speed violence and momentum
yeah mutual's a doctor disrespect on
twitter dr disrespect is probably better
than he carried chess for being honest
for a moment
i have a strategy robert that i think
will work out hikar are you uh are you
teaching xuc at all
if he wants me to i will yeah yeah
demonstrate
yeah we'll have to go
just you know i'll just slide in your
dms don't worry about what we're gonna
talk about but you know
just whatever you teach them i'll just
be talking to you right after
after an hour
one week man i feel a little ignored
over here like robert
look i'm sorry who did you coach out of
curiosity okay don't give me that
attitude i'm just wondering who did you
coach that play today was it whoa
what the
hell
i'm just asking questions i'm sorry i'm
just an interviewer what can i say
look i know robert you have two lessons
and i'll follow them till i die
confidence and don't say sorry
there we go
that that's that's a big part of it but
but i don't want to learn your london
because that didn't work for at all
akaru actually taught me the london
originally yes
originally yeah it worked against
so i was i was pulling it out again but
then i'm gonna all right so i'm gonna
hit him
i'm getting pods i'm hitting up pods
is the goat
hans work with who slicker and um
and me baby and meek and we're going all
the way i'm excited to play xqc i think
it'll be interesting okay when is it is
there a date
uh
not tomorrow over the death of tomorrow
i think yeah okay okay okay
all right well i have never i have never
lost a single game in any loser's
bracket tournament ever and that's not
about a change it never happened never
will so i'll see you in two days man
i'll see you then bud
all right i'll see you guys
goodbye bye bye thanks bruce lee thank
you
and we see in the consolation bracket
now we have xqc
taking on ludwig i think nobody is
rooting for ludwig anymore i think he's
lost all of his fans just by he burned
bridges i've been in the film from the
start haven't i haven't i been the
villain from the start it's okay it's
consolation all right no one needs a
hero i was doing the batman voices
before the show and now you became the
joker i i'm down for the joker all right
the the top brackets that's where the
heroes are that's where the that's where
like the the anime naruto is down here
it's all villains it's all
and at the end of the day
we'll see who wins we'll see who wins
i'm just gonna wait i'm gonna let my
play talk all right well in this bracket
how about up top voidboy versus box box
that's a pretty big match up there is it
all voyboy in your opinion
i
i don't know boy boy box box is the most
interesting one because box boxes
motivation to enter was playing boy boy
but boy boy just seems like a different
he's
he's a different animal he's just cut
different
uh i feel like he can read the vorski's
and then be gm in like five years if he
tried
so i i don't know i feel nervous my boy
box box but i'm rooting for box box the
whole way and i think hutch has it on
the other side for sure
hey car you agree with that
um yeah i mean i think hutch is a big
favorite for sure i think uh voy boy and
box box unless box box does some special
preparation in advance of the match and
he's catches voyboy in something i think
boy boy is the big favorite but anything
can happen and um and i i don't think
it's going to be smooth sailing the way
that everyone thinks it will before
what i do expect
well i think the most important question
that we have remaining is between moist
critical and slicker okay that's the
match-up of the semi-finals here no
offense ludwig and
what do you think
between charlie and slicker yeah i mean
i think i think charlie is probably the
favorite he's been playing a lot of
chess doing a lot of lessons i think
i've seen him streaming chess literally
every day for the last week i think now
so he's just been putting a lot of time
his rating has improved a lot so i think
he's probably the big favorite but uh
slicker is probably getting some some
coaching as well so so again you assume
that they're favorites but but we'll see
and um and so i'm hoping charlie can win
because then he'll then he'll play uh
probably play felix in the final
bracket
isn't there somebody else yukaru what's
going
on i'll put anything all right i've seen
how you play valor you're a one-trick
pony walking around shooting can't hold
an angle
all of a sudden you think you can start
beating on horses
[Laughter]
watch yourself man watch yourself i'm
going to stream snipe all your ballerina
games today
because of that okay okay bring it on
man bring it on anyway but yeah i think
it's it's going to be great i'm just
glad that everybody's having a good time
more than anything um so it's just going
to be great to see the last couple of
matches and of course good luck to you
as well look like that if i lose i'm
burning bridges all right everybody at
chess.com can eat my
i better win i better win i'm gonna i'm
ooh
i'm i'm expecting to be hit up later
with an apology hey can you can you help
me now but i may say no but lo we're
gonna serious no it's been really fun
having you on for the call you play xqc
next so next time we see you you'll be a
player instead of a commentator i'll see
you all friday and uh i think i think
any of the four would be hype but i
don't want to lose
all right well
we're going to be checking you out i
guess hikaru is not going to be rooting
for you but i'll root for you i got you
thanks robert thank you you know what i
said earlier man about you being a
history major and that being a waste of
time i didn't mean that i think it's
actually so cool
so you just want me to erase the history
that we just had here all this beef no
you know what we're calling the show
everybody thank you so much all you've
been tuning in you're so cool robert
yeah no sorry keep your eyes great keep
going with the auto it's so good
don't interrupt me next time then so
yeah it was a pleasure until it stopped
being a pleasure to have love being
along for the commentary we will see the
semi finals next there will be more pot
champs tomorrow but for now enjoy the
rest of your evening and have a good one